[Musique]
c'est presque inconcevable que la
gaspésie soit demeuré aussi pauvre
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était en 1930
pourquoi ya depuis que l'université
laval compile des données donc on
remonte jusqu'aux années 90 vous êtes
quand même le plus vieux doctorants ça
vous fait quoi
je jure sa couronne ja couronne une
démarche scientifique sa couronne aussi
labeur considérable mais je suis d'abord
été moins puis on n'abdique pas son
passé on tourne pas le dos la région
d'in ze mis au monde
[Musique]
- matthias rioux affirme solennellement
que je remplirai le devoirs de ma charge
de ministre du travail
plus fondamentalement c'est venu quand
j'étais ministre régional j'allais dans
les petits villages dévitalisés c'était
d'une tristesse incroyable je me disais
je me pose toujours la même question
pourquoi ce retard là j'ai dit bon ben
c'est le temps d'attaquer maintenant la
péninsule et l'examiner dans tous ses
états quel constat que vous faites
aujourd'hui sur l'état d'esprit du fitr
est temps on disait aussi loin la
gaspésie c'est froid l'hiver les gens
sont pauvres sont ils les trient on a
stigmatisé la région l'état n'a pas
développé deux modèles rurale de
développement
le seul problème les politiques
publiques n'ont pas eu d'effet le
développement de la gaspésie va se faire
avec ou sans l'état les ya des gens chez
nous regardent plaisir extrêmement
compétent qualifié
qui ont développé une pensée économique
et social vous avez passé beaucoup de
temps ici comme il tente atteindre 7,6
c'est plus qu'une bibliothèque stains
temple les bailleurs réflexion de
l'approfondissement de ma démarche c'est
ici que ce cépage je ne voyais pas ce
soir c'était mon lieu de travail et les
gens m'ont accueilli comme ça j'ai perdu
ma clé usb avec tout fallu des cris mais
il fallait la décrypter et sans cet
apport n'a pas de la tarte
que pensez vous de l'état du parti
québécois en 2018 à la veille des
élections situe devant
qu'est ce que je pense du mouvement
souverainiste l'indépendantisme est
devenue pléthorique divisé contre
lui-même
mais je pense qu'il va falloir prendre
la route
c'est sur le terrain que ça se gagne une
élection c'est sacré des réveils de
sortir par les convainc cette flamme là
je ne la vois plus